i've always wanted to fly supersonic and
when i was a kid there was only one way
to do that the anglo-french concord
airliner is making a first run under its
own path concorde was just this
engineering marvel traveling faster than
the speed of sound
but before i could fly on one this was
the scene after july's concord crash a
concord flight crashed shortly after
takeoff killing 113 people and soon
after the plane stopped flying for good
commercial supersonic flight went away
but now some are trying to bring it back
we're starting off with what we call
overture which is a big leap forward
from concord if they succeed they could
once again revolutionize how we fly
supersonic flight over land really
expands uh the market potential but that
success could hang on one sound the
sonic boom
the question is can you make that go
away so is supersonic flight coming back
well that's why i'm at this air museum
in england because if you want to know
how to get super sonic to succeed you
need to know what killed off concord so
to find out i'm finally going to step
furthermore let's go
so i think it's somewhere back here oh
my god it's there
look at it it's incredible
this is concord 101 it's one of the very
early prototype concords and it's
displayed here at the stage that nasa
lockheed and boom are at at the moment
that early development phase take a look
at these names they explain part of the
reason why concord didn't last at a cost
of a hundred million pounds the
development will be undertaken by the
british aircraft corporation and so
daviacion of france concord wasn't born
out of a company chasing a commercial
demand for supersonic flight it was
created by two countries france and the
uk it was created by government
ministries built by government factories
and used by government airlines that's
richard abellafia an aviation analyst at
teal group and the airlines he's talking
about are air france and british airways
who bought concord from their
governments for a fraction of the cost
everybody involved cooperated in
subsidizing concord it was difficult to
not go along with it because there was
so much pride at stake the planes flew
principally from new york to london and
paris with a one-way trip taking as
little as three hours and even though a
round trip cost around ten thousand
dollars by 1999 passengers were still
willing to pay for that speed the
operators of course saw it as a flagship
it's a great way of attracting premium
passengers part of the reason those
tickets were so expensive was that
concord was just really expensive to run
everybody involved whether it was the
builders or the operators were losing
money on concord it was incredibly fuel
thirsty and costly to operate and
maintain
and then two events happened that would
spell the beginning of the end of
concord the first a crash in 2000 which
killed 113 people and grounded the plane
and the second 911 which saw a major
decline in air traffic soon after that
airbus announced they would no longer
support the craft and with passenger
numbers never recovering for concord in
2003 ba and air france stopped flying
finally stepping on board
oh wow this thing's incredible
and i really wish i would have done this
when i was a kid because i do not fit
i'm six foot five and it is very cramped
in here
let's go check out the cockpit
now this goes to show just how much it
took to keep concord in the air but one
of concorde's biggest limiting factors
happened before the plane ever carried
passengers
there are a variety of
reasons why i'm opposed to the concord
under the present circumstances
one primarily is the
noise see concord's biggest selling
point was that it could travel faster
than the speed of sound but when an
object passes through that sound barrier
it can create a sonic boom and they're
not exactly quiet we're not talking
about average plane noise here
sonic boom sound more like explosions
they can break windows
at the start of this year sonic boom
from a jet shook the windows of my house
this is from a nearby doorbell camera
needless to say this annoys people and
generally rules out the idea of
supersonic fights over land in 1973 the
faa bought into effect a regulation that
prohibited civilian aircraft from flying
faster than the speed of sound over u.s
land other countries soon followed suit
this dramatically limited the routes
that concord could effectively operate
on to trans-oceanic ones now that same
faa regulation is still in effect today
but the faa have said that they're
considering policy and regulatory
changes that could result in new noise
certification standards for overland
supersonic aircraft essentially the
change could mean that you could fly
supersonic over land and that would open
up new routes and possibly change the
economics of this but only if your plane
is quiet enough but how do you make a
plane that goes supersonic without going
boom
surely that defies the physics of this
right well physics isn't my strong suit
but fortunately i have a colleague with
our own youtube channel on health and
science and you can subscribe to that
here hey daniela wow hey danielle we all
say sonic boom but what is it what
actually causes it sound is basically
waves moving through the through the air
so when you have a sound that those
waves like basically bounce off those
molecules until they hit your ear that
happens at a certain speed so when
something is moving through the air like
at the speed of sound or faster
those waves kind of build up they build
up in such a way that there's a lot of
pressure right so you're traveling at
the same speed as those molecules and
they have nowhere to go right yeah when
the the aircraft busts through that
pressure buildup you have the sonic boom
got it so the pressure is released all
at once and that's what makes the sound
okay okay so how on earth do you make
that quieter it comes down to the design
of the aircraft so you can find a way in
which to minimize that pressure build up
or to
dissipate it so that it cracks open over
a longer period of time and then that
will help minimize the amount of noise
that you hear
to try and disperse that sonic boom nasa
and lockheed have developed this the
x-59 a quiet supersonic demonstrator
plane first goal is to
show that we can design an aircraft for
a low sonic thumb and then the ultimate
goal is to actually fly this aircraft
over communities and establish their
tolerance for that sonic thump they're
aiming for the craft to have a perceived
loudness level or pldb of 75. it's
comparable to say your neighbor closing
their car door across the street for
reference the the pldb of concord was on
the order of 107. we're not completely
eliminating the boom we're just bringing
it down to a level where it'll blend
into people's everyday lives for now the
x-59 can only fit one person the pilot
and they can't even see forward through
the window due to the design of the
plane
but for nasa the aim here isn't to
create a commercial supersonic aircraft
but instead fly their low sonic boom
aircraft over neighborhoods and gauge
how the public reacts that information
will then help the faa reassess their
regulations our ultimate goal is to
provide them this dose response
relationship information from our
community testing and in the hopes of of
changing regulations and allowing
overland supersonic flight lockheed and
nasa told me that they expect the faa to
make a decision on the noise limits for
overland supersonic flight by 2035.
if the faa do change those regulations
there's at least one company that might
take advantage of that in june united
airlines placed an order for 15 planes
from boom supersonic a denver-based
startup that launched in 2014 and has
raised over 270 million dollars from
investors there's this incredible
appetite for how do we make high-speed
flight available everywhere that's their
ceo blake shelf we're started focusing
on transoceanic roots but boy that is
just the start right now boom is still
in the development phase and is working
on their x1b demonstrator it's in ground
test now it's going to be on a runway
around the end of the year starting to
fly next year the company has hopes to
start flying passengers in 2029 using
its overture 1 aircraft which the
company says will fly at mach 1.7 using
sustainable aviation fuels it's likely
that overture 1 will still make a sonic
boom but boom ceo told me that he's
monitoring the work that nasa and
lockheed are doing and that future boom
aircraft will be optimized to hit any
new target noise levels there's a lot of
innovation to be had in terms of
improving the efficiency of the airplane
and
yes also be able to do high-speed flight
unrestricted everywhere
so if the faa changes regulations and if
boom's next generation of planes comply
with those regulations will it be enough
for commercial supersonic flight to
finally be economically sustainable well
some analysts think not because even if
you can fly supersonic anywhere you
still need to be able to find passengers
who can afford tickets
just as in concord's day it's a question
of finding enough people with enough
money on enough routes and that last
part is key richard told me that he
believes that market may be pretty small
but boom say that they plan to try and
lower operational costs to encourage
lower ticket prices and attract a wider
range of customers we're focused on
reducing the cost of operation and
setting up the entire
ecosystem so they're going to be
economies of scale so we're targeting
roughly a 75 reduction in cost per
passenger even if boom can achieve that
they still might not be able to fly
everywhere and that's due to fuel range
the obvious routes in the pacific uh
like
new york to tokyo can't happen because
these things really like to drink fuel
so that's not a valid route it would
have to stop in alaska and hawaii or
something and that would obviate any of
the advantage associated with supersonic
flight and still even if they can solve
both of those issues richard thinks that
there's still one thing that may stop
commercial supersonic flight becoming
mainstream and that's things like this
see back in concord's day i couldn't
stay connected while i was flying and
how long i was in the air for really
mattered but nowadays
i can just work on the plane
why are you rushing to get somewhere
more importantly why are you paying an
awful lot more to get a much smaller
space just to save a couple of hours
will you be connected anyway so will we
see commercial supersonic flight in the
skies once more well it's likely that
those planes may find a route to market
as commercial business jets where ticket
pricing can be a little more elastic but
achieving the right design to open up
new routes and lower those ticket prices
and make these planes a common feature
in our skies is going to be a huge
challenge and if companies exploring
supersonic get it wrong
their aircraft may end up in a museum
like this one and my supersonic dreams
will continue to be unfulfilled
hey thanks for making it to the end of
the video it really means a lot to me so
do you think you'll ever fly supersonic
let me know in the comments below and as
always if you're interested in the
future of how we might be getting from a
to b then don't forget to subscribe see
you soon